Wagner forces leave the city of rostov
vondon in southern Russia
instead of Moscow they're reportedly
heading to their old positions on the
front lines in Ukraine Russian President
Vladimir Putin called Wagner leader
Evgeni pregosin a traitor but as he left
rostov pregojin was chilled by a crowd
it all ended perfectly well thank god
with minimal casualties I think good job
I believe this was the right thing to do
under a deal reportedly brokered by the
president of Belarus pregojin has left
for that country while some of his
mercenaries are to be integrated into
the Russian army but some doubt whether
this will be the end of the Wagner group
or its founder it's a big question I
mean you know yesterday with a giant
pirani and Vladimir Putin called it
treason and today suddenly they all
forgiven and he's going to Belarus
hard to know and hard to know Belarus is
a small country Evgeni pregosian is a
man of of giant projects and so it's
kind of hard to see what exactly he is
going to be doing there after nearly 24
hours of tension calm has returned to
the Russian Capital yet many are
concerned about what this Rebellion May
mean in the long term
the fact that this deal appears to have
given pagosian a sort of free pardon to
retire into Belarus and that the Wagner
mercenaries will be absorbed into the
regular Russian army is perhaps a
surprise but it's also the reason why I
think this Saga isn't finally over
because I find it very hard to believe
that pagosian will have a quiet peaceful
retirement in Belarus President Putin
has not made any public comment since
the agreement was announced nor has
there been any word from defense
minister Sergey shoigu whom previous
mentioned by name as the target of the
Rebellion
getting rid of the Russian military High
command and the defense minister
we might perhaps see Putin move to do
that once he can claimed that he is not
doing so Under Pressure but of his own
volition many analysts agree that
uncertainty surrounds both Russia's
military operations and its leaders
political future
Daniel Hawkins is in Moscow and says it
could take weeks for the situations
surrounding Wagner and its leader to
become clearer
well since this uh this incident has
been resolved progression has been very
quiet
um his uh social media Pages have
organized social media Pages have been
shut down the offices have been closed
so I think the Russian authorities want
to project this image that it's very
much game over
um for Wagner
um in Russia but of course progression
remains very popular among his Fighters
he claimed to have command of 25 000
Fighters uh even more
um many of them perhaps will be very
hesitant to assign contracts with the
Russian mod that was part of the offer
given to them um to lay down arms it's
unclear what role is going to have in
Belarus whose protection is going to be
under
um it's unlikely that um he'll be
allowed to keep command of his imaginers
and move them over to to Belarus
certainly
um there's implications of course Beyond
Russian borders Russia has a Wagner
rather has a heavy presence in Africa
where the Kremlin is used to project use
the private military contractors to
project their political and economic
interests now that Wagner is effectively
I guess you could say dissolved or taken
on the different control different
management what implications is going to
have for Russia's interests uh across
the borders and one of irrigations of
course will this have a force for
Ukraine where Wagner was Russia's best
and most effective uh fighting force all
these questions remain unanswered uh
Lucha pescop has said very clearly that
Wagner Fighters will not face any
repercussions for what happened and then
progression there the charges against
him will be dropped very serious charges
of our Mutiny carrying after 20 years in
jail
um what exact role and what relationship
you'll have with the Kremlin if there is
going to be in a relationship is very
much in the air at the moment and I
think we'll see exactly what's going to
happen uh in the coming weeks